[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-Hello, and welcome to this
week's Chrome Apps Hangout!
Glad you joined us.
Today, we're going to cover
the Text-to-Speech API.
With that, I'd like to invite
Pete LePage to join us and get
things started!
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PETE LEPAGE: Well
hey, everybody.
My name's Pete LePage.
I'm a developer advocate with
the Chrome Team working on
Chrome Apps.
Today, I want to talk to you
about the Text-To-Speech API,
one of the cool new
APIs that are
available with Chrome Apps.
As you saw, we had a little demo
there that took what I
had to say, used the
Text-To-Speech API and was
able to convert that from
text into the speech.
So you can use this for
all kinds of different
applications.
Whether you want to have a
clock that talks to you,
whether you want to have an
application that alerts you
when you get new text messages,
or anything else
that you might want to have
a voice coming out of your
computer for any kind
of experience.
So with that, I figure we might
as well just jump in and
have a look at the
application.
So let's bring up some
code and the app.
So here, we've got
the application.
Let me just move my computer
to a place where I can more
easily access it here.
And you'll notice that there's
a couple of things in this
text box that I've got going.
I've got a text box that
I can edit in here.
So I can say, the
rain in Spain.
Spain stays mainly
in the plain.
Right?
And I can click on
the Speak button.
Sure enough--
It helps if I turn
the volume up.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-In the plain.
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PETE LEPAGE: Let's
try that again.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-The rain in Spain stay
mainly in the plain.
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PETE LEPAGE: So we've got
it saying whatever
we want it to say.
As well as it says each part,
you'll notice that it
highlights the words
that it's saying.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-The rain in Spain, stay
mainly in the plain.
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PETE LEPAGE: Ah, helps
if I remember to put
my extra S on there.
But it says the words that it's
speaking as it moves through.
So I'm going to walk you through
how I went about going
and using the Text-To-Speech
API, but as well, how I went
and got it to highlight the
different words as it moved
through the different pieces.
So let's bring up some code here
and, before we jump into
the actual app, let's
take a look at the
code behind the app.
So I started, in this particular
case, with just the
simple Hello, World example
because I figured that was the
easiest place for me
to get started.
It was just a nice,
easy place to go.
I used the Bootstrap UI to make
things look kind of nice,
as just a starting place.
Just a real easy thing.
So you can see here, I've got
the Bootstrap CSS framework,
and then I've got my own custom
set of styles so that I
can have a certain set
of things in there.
If we have a look at that custom
set of styles, all I've
gone and done is I just put
some special styling on my
container so that I'd have just
enough for that top block
to be there.
And as well, I created
this highlight class.
The highlight class
is what's actually
highlighting each word.
So each word, when it gets
highlighted, has that class
added to it and removed
from it.
So that's the CSS behind this.
If we go back and have a look
at the application, you can
ignore this top little bit.
This is where we've got the
toolbar across the top.
So if I bring the app
back up here.
Let me just bring it
up here real quick.
Right so, here we go.
There's my top navbar
so that you can see
what's going on there.
I didn't do anything special
with it because I just wanted
to get something in
really quickly.
But then here in my container,
I've done a couple of things.
So I've got a form element that
I've said form inline.
So that styles the Bootstrap
stuff, so that I've got my
text in line with the button.
Now I've got my text input here,
and I've set it so that
it's a type text.
And I've given it an ID because
I'm going to need to
grab it in a second.
I've specified how big I
want the input to be.
And I've also put in a little
place holder, so that if we go
and get rid of any of the text
in here, we always will see
"say something" so that we
know that that's where we
should go type and provide
our information.
I've got a button that, by
default, is disabled.
We'll talk about why I've
got it disabled to
begin with in a sec.
And it's type button
with an ID.
And the class button is what
defines the styling for the
Bootstrap button.
And then a little bit further
down, I have a paragraph where
I've actually gone in to find
all of my word lists.
So this is where we're going
to go in and insert all the
words as we start iterating
through these.
Let's take a quick look at the
manifest file, because the
manifest file is
pretty simple.
There's nothing really complex
to it or anything like that.
It's a pretty standard
manifest file.
Again, I just grabbed this from
the Hello, World sample.
The only thing that really
changes that I want to
highlight here is in the
permissions element.
So in the permissions element,
what I've done is I've added
permissions for TTS,
so Text-To-Speech.
And that's the Chrome
Text-To-Speech element.
The only other thing that I
did was I moved my main.js
into a JavaScript folder because
I like to keep all my
JavaScript off into its own
little space so that it's not
sitting in my root
of the directory.
So if we actually look at that,
you could see it's just
a standard main.js.
We go and create a window that
opens index at about 500
pixels wide and 309
pixels in height.
So that's going to go
and open our window.
It's going to give us our
Text-To-Speech permission.
So we're pretty much good
to go at this point.
So at this point, let's go and
actually take a look at what's
going on with our code.
But before I do that, I want
to mention that, as with
pretty much all of our Chrome
Hangouts, if you have
questions, if you've got
comments, if you want to know
what's going on with some of
these, feel free to post your
questions at our
moderator page.
The link is there onscreen.
I'll leave it onscreen for the
next couple minutes so that as
I'm walking through this, you
can go ahead and post your
questions and ask
what's going on.
All right.
Now, I kind of put this example
together in a quick
and dirty fashion, and some
of the things I did here I
wouldn't recommend doing
for a production app.
But it at least gives you a good
idea of how to go about
doing some of these things.
So I created three variables,
because I was going to need to
access these fairly
frequently.
So my speakInput, which is my
text box, my btnSpeak, which
is the button that the user
clicks when they want to go
and hit a button, and
then the wordList.
So that's the paragraph
that we've got.
And in my jQuery Document Ready
function, I go and I
just grab those right
off the bat.
So that way I've always
got them.
I don't have to go keep
searching for them every time
the user hits a button,
or anything like that.
It's a good performance
technique.
Obviously, in something like
this, it's maybe not the most
important thing to have because
this is such a simple
example, but I wanted to
just go stick this in
there, and go from that.
So I go and grab my speakInput,
which is the text
box, I grab the button, and
I grab the wordList.
And then I bind with a click.
So when the user clicks on the
button, they actually go in
and call the saySomething
function.
Now the other thing that I did
is I added a removeAttr
disabled here.
So that way, that button is
not enabled until our
document's ready.
The user is not going to be able
to do something before
your UI is ready, so disabling
buttons when they're not
available is just one of those
things that generally is a
good practice, good thing
to keep an eye on.
So now let's take a look at
our saySomething function.
So this is the function that
gets called when the user goes
and clicks on Say Something.
So let me pop over here,
and when I say, yes--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-Yes.
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PETE LEPAGE: --sure
enough, that's the
function that gets called.
So let's take a look.
So the first thing I wanted to
do is get my list of words.
So I just go and use the val
from the input, and I just put
all of those words
into an array.
And I split those into
an array of words.
Now, I split them into an
array of words because I
wanted to know where all the
different words existed.
So that as I went through and
highlighted each, as the
computer said each word, I
could highlight each one.
So actually I'm going to go and
I'm going to stick in a
console.log, "Words," colon,
and we'll add words.
Just so that when we have a look
this here in a sec, we
can see what's going on.
So the next thing that happens
is that I take the wordList,
and I get rid of everything
in there.
Because we don't care what was
in there before, so we want to
go through and clear
everything out.
And then I want to go through,
and I add all of the words
into a span.
So each word becomes its own
span inside my wordList.
So I go through and add each
of those guys in there.
And I just say, span, word,
text, go in, stick each one
in, and then append
it to my wordList.
Now, probably not the best way
to do this because in this
particular case, I am having
to refer to that each one.
And going in and appending, and
appending, and appending,
and appending ends up being a
pretty expensive DOM task.
The better way to do this would
have been to create an
element that I would have
wrapped everything in, put
everything into that particular
element, and then
just added that one single
element to my page.
Depending on how much time we
have, we might go in and add
that in a sec.
So now I use the Chrome
Text-To-Speech API.
And the Chrome Text-To-Speech
API, let me just pull that guy
out for a sec here.
You can get the documentation
for the Chrome Text-To-Speech
API here if you go
and look at that.
But there's a couple of things
that you can do with this.
So the easiest API that you can
use is chrome.tts.speak
and you provide it
with a string.
And it goes and it'll say
whatever you wanted it to say.
It's an asynchronous call.
Keep that in mind.
So that you say, hey, I want
you to go say this.
And it's going to immediately
come back and say, OK, great
I'm saying this.
And the rest of your JavaScript
is running.
So that means you're
not waiting for
it to finish speaking.
It also means that you can use
this text-to-speech stop to
stop it from saying anything.
If it's still continually
talking and you're like, oh
hey, I don't want you to
keep talking anymore,
you can have it stop.
But then there's a bunch of
functions and parameters that
you can provide.
And the interesting one
that I used, was
the callback function.
So let me actually
go back to here.
So you can see here we said
Chrome Text-To-Speech toSay,
which is the list of words that
we want the user to say.
Right?
And then I provided a couple
of parameters.
So one parameter I provided
was the rate.
So 1.0 would be a normal pace.
Increasing that to a higher
number will be
have them speak faster.
Decreasing that number,
they're going to speak
(SPEAKING SLOWLY) more slowly,
and they're not going to sound
very interesting.
So I thought that 1.0 actually
sounded a little too fast, so
that's why I put
it down at 0.8.
Now, the next piece I added
was an onEvent function.
The onEvent function fires under
a number of different
events, but the one that I
thought was the coolest was
the word function.
So on every word that
Chrome says, it
fires this word function.
So I checked to see what the
word function is, and go in
and add that and check
to see if it's there.
It comes back and it gives me
the character index of where
that word is.
So that I can see OK,
well, this is--
it's starting at this character,
or this character
as it says something.
Then I find all spans that have
the highlight, and I want
to go and remove them.
Because I'm not interested in
highlighting anything else.
I only want to highlight
the active word.
Now, this is one place where I
got a little goofed up when I
first did this.
Actually, let's take a look
at what I just added here,
because the words that
I split out don't
actually split by word.
It actually splits
by character.
So if I pull this
guy up-- whoop.
I guess I have to do these.
All right.
So let's pull this up again,
and let's reload this.
And we'll have a look at
what's going on here.
And--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-The rain in Spain
stays mainly--
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PETE LEPAGE: So sure enough,
there's the rain in Spain
stays mainly in the plain.
You'll notice that it's
broken down each
letter into each piece.
Now the reason I had to break
down each letter, is that
Chrome considers words to be
something that I didn't
consider words to be.
Chrome considers words to be
what I would traditionally
consider a word.
But a comma is considered
a word.
So if you'll notice just that
simple "the rain in Spain," it
thinks that is a word.
So what I went and did is I
said, OK, well we need to just
highlight each piece until
we find the end of what I
consider to be a word.
So let me pop back
to our code here.
And I go through and I say,
while we're in a word, add the
highlight to that word.
And we do it by the index.
And we keep going until either
we find the end of the string,
or we find a space at
the end of our text.
So if words start is undefined,
or if words start
dot text equals space, then
we've finished with our word.
So if we do that, that breaks
down each individual word.
Once we hit the end, we're
going to finish with the
particular space.
So let's actually go in and
console.log(event).
So that we can see what's being
passed in, and how each
word comes in and how
long each word is.
All right.
And then we've just got an empty
function for any kind
errors or anything like that.
So I'm going to save this guy,
and we'll reload this.
And Inspect, so that we bring
up for our console.
And bring up our Developer
Console, and go ahead and
Speak this.
Now, I've got it muted so that
you don't hear each piece, but
let me move this in so
that you can see this
a little bit better.
OK, we'll do that.
And sure enough.
So you can see we've got an
object that's the start with
our character index of 0.
There's no error message.
Then the second one, we
start our first word.
And our first word goes
from 0 to something.
It doesn't actually tell
us where it ends.
And then our second word
starts at character 4.
OK, so there is character
0, 1, 2, 3, and so sure
enough there's 4.
Let me bring up a slightly
different example, where we
can see this a little
bit more clearly.
So I'm going to put a comma
right in the very beginning.
Hello, world.
Of course.
So sure enough--
I'm just going to clear my
console here, so we can see
this a little bit better.
So "Hello, world."
So sure enough, you see right
off the bat we have start, we
have hello at 0.
We have word at 5 characters,
so that we can go in, and we
can go to our 5 characters
in, which is the comma.
And then world starts at 7.
So we've got, "Hello, world."
We start with our next word.
We highlight the next
thing and highlight
that as it goes on.
So you can see it's a pretty
simple example to be able to
go through and highlight each
of the sets of words, as we
move through.
And it's a pretty quick, easy
way to be able to go in and
say, all right, well, I want
something to go to speak, or I
want something to be able to go
and add in whatever else is
we particularly want.
Now it looks like our friend
Renato has just joined us.
So I'm going to bring
Renato in here.
One second.
Let me just close something up
real quick, and bring him in.
And Renato, how you doing?
I'm not hearing you there.
Yeah.
All right.
One sec, let me see if I can
change something real fast.
All right.
Looks like I'm not hearing
Renato right now, so we'll
have Renato join us on another
Hangout on a future date.
So with that, I want to open
it up to any questions that
you guys have.
Actually, before I do
that, what I'll do--
the sample that I wrote, you
can go and grab that.
The link is onscreen.
If you want to go in and pull
that up so that you can try
this out yourself.
See how it works.
It's just up on my
GitHub account.
You can go and grab that
from there, and see how
it works for you.
But with that, I'll open
it up to questions.
Let me pull them up, and see
if we've got any good, fun
questions for us this week.
All right.
All right, so we've got a
couple questions here.
So the first question, "Since
this is a Chrome API, does it
only work with the
Chrome browser.
Or if I had to format it in
HTML, would it also work in
Safari?"
So this is a particular feature
of Chrome Apps.
So it's not going to work in
Safari, or in Firefox, or
anything like that.
It's got to be within a Chrome
app, or it can also work in a
Chrome extension as
well, I believe.
Pretty sure about that one.
I haven't used that one
in a little while.
But you can use that
within Chrome Apps.
There is a new Text-To-Speech
API.
It's either a Text-To-Speech API
or Speech-To-Text API that
just landed as part of the Open
Web Platform, that you
may be able to use
and check out.
It's a pretty useful one and
really kind of cool.
Because it will allow you to
do a lot of things that
developers have been asking for
for quite some time and
just simply haven't been able
to do with the stuff that
they've got going on.
So let's see if there's
another question here.
All right.
So the next question is, "Where
are some of the things
you would might run into
problems when using this?"
So the couple of things that
I ran into when I was doing
this, one was really around
the piece of understanding
which words are coming out.
Because it only gives you
that start piece.
And the things that Chrome
thinks are words, like a
comma, a period, perhaps
a new paragraph.
I actually didn't try
that in my code.
Those may come across as
something a little bit odd.
So you'll need to experiment
with those a little bit.
The other thing that you'll just
have to make sure that
you do is make sure that you've
got the Chrome TTS API
enabled, so that way you
can go and use this.
In fact, let me bring up the
docs again, one sec.
So if you have a look here in
the docs, it does go through
and have a pretty good set of
documentation about some of
the other things that
you can do.
So it talks about the listening
for events with the
different pieces.
Unfortunately, I couldn't get
in Chrome Canary the SSML
markup to work.
I'm going to go check to see if
that was a problem with my
implementation, or if that's
maybe a bug in Chrome.
And file a bug.
So just keep an eye out on our
Google Developers page for a
little bit more information
about that.
One of the other things that I
thought was kind of neat that
you can do is actually be able
to go and choose a couple of
different voices.
So you heard when I
did it earlier.
Let me pull this guy out to see
if I could find this and
bring it up.
Right?
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-Hello, world.
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PETE LEPAGE: Here we go.
Let's try that.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-Hello, world
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PETE LEPAGE: You hear "hello,
world." It's there.
It kind of sounds like
a robotic male voice.
It's not exactly very great to
be able to tell what's going
on or anything like that.
With something like that, what
you could do is change to a
different voice.
Now, when I ran through the
sample code here, again, it
turned out that on my particular
computer, I
couldn't get it to come up
with many other voices.
It only had the one
default voice.
So it depends on the different
computer that you've got what
voices you may have access to,
and whether you can change
from a male to a female, whether
you can maybe add a
British accent, or Canadian
accent, where everybody says
"oot and aboot." That
kind of fun stuff.
So it's a quick easy way to be
able to change the accents and
that kind of stuff.
All right.
So with that, it's a pretty
simple sample.
And let me put the link it up
again so that we can see, and
you can grab that if you want.
But the sample code is there
at goo.gl/PJSdM And you can
grab that code.
You can go play with it.
Jim's just posted, "Does
it work with the French
language?" Yeah, it does.
So basically the way that it
does this is it does it either
locally on your computer, or it
potentially it may go up to
the cloud and use Google
services to go in and do the
translation.
So in fact, Jim let me try this,
and we'll see how good
its accent is.
Let's pop this guy up here.
So here, I'll make it nice
and big for us, so
we can see it here.
So I've got, "Bon jour." My
French is awful, but--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-Bonjour.
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, its
French accent is
about as bad as mine.
But you may be able to set it
into the French language.
In fact, let's have
a quick peek.
If I bring the docs back
up here, I believe
that you can set.
Yeah, so here, TTS Voice
Language, you can set the
language that you
want it to use.
So by default it's going to use
whichever the user is in.
But you could change it to
FRFR, or FRCA, or ZHFR,
whatever language you
particularly want it to use.
So it's really possible
to do a lot of
neat things with this.
You can go to the male, the
female voice, or anything like
that pretty quickly, pretty
easily without having to do
too much crazy stuff.
So with that, I'm going to
wrap it up for this week.
It's a little bit of a
short one this week.
But I say thank you
guys very much.
Hope you enjoyed this.
We'll be back next week.
Paul, Renato, and the rest
of the crew will be here.
And we'll jump in, and talk
about some more cool Chrome
Apps stuff.
All right, everybody,
thanks a lot.
Have a great day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]